it looks like fauci must have missed a
key new detail with warning America
according to the Washington Post for the
first time ever vaccinated people now
make up a majority of coveted deaths by
58
and while the White House can't let go
of covid another huge Health crisis is
sweeping across the country pharmacists
are running out of Children's Tylenol
after a crippling antibiotic shortages
more and more kids are being
hospitalized with the debilitating RSV
which is a respiratory virus
okay Lawrence I'm going to start with
you were you happier sad that that was
fauci's last press conference uh I think
most of America is excited about that
she's leaving
um it wasn't always that way Doug I
think the American public people in the
the media even I said Fox we praise fast
at the beginning but it became the it
was the lies that did the marker for him
and he's the type of liar that lies
because I want to help you and it
started with the mask if you guys
remember we didn't have a mass issue
before people were rushing to the store
they were hoarding the supply everybody
wanted a mask and then falchi along with
some of the other White House doctors
went out there and they said the mass
don't work so people stop getting them
that wasn't true the mass didn't work
was just a total lie they wanted to
hoard the Supply right for the folks
that were working in the hospital he
could have just told the people that
then it was the vaccine he said okay if
you get the vaccine you can't die from
covet we all know that was a lie they
knew that was a lie at the time but he
said he did that because he wanted
people to get the vaccine and then the
final thing and this is just the one
that we still need answers on was when
it came to gain of function he know for
a fact that we funded every research he
know what he did he played a semantic
game with Rand Paul but in his eyes they
needed to get ahead of the research they
needed to know what the buyers could
potentially do so it was necessary well
you know what Dagan one of the questions
one of the final questions was to fauci
can you tell us about the origin of
covet a perfectly fair question given
that Millions died across the world and
yet there was like a defense from Kareem
Jean-Pierre which I'm going to ask Greg
about but I'll go to you on the issue of
you know why was that something that he
shouldn't have to answer because the his
division at government was funneling
money through the Eco Health Alliance to
the very lab that could be the site very
likely the site of the coronavirus he's
going to get call on Capitol Hill
to talk about this
let's take a listen
hold on one second
we have a process here I'm not calling
out on people who yell she has a valid
question she's asked about the origin of
coffee I hear the questions
I hear your question but we're not doing
this the way you want it this is a
disrespectful it is I'm done Simon I'm
done I'm Simon I'm done I'm done with
you right now
wow I'll let you just finish on that
thought and then I want to go to Greg on
Korean Jean-Pierre no the only nice
thing I have to say about Tony fauci are
too Tony fauci is bye don't let the door
hit you where the good Lord split you
actually I hope the door does hit you on
the ass goodbye he is a contemptible
partisan power hungry Bureau hack
and the danger is he's a perfect example
of why somebody should never be in a
position of power for that long he is he
was to paraphrase Brit Hume he is an
epidemiologist you should have been in
charge of fighting the disease not our
economy not our children's development
not businesses not our children's
education none of it trillions of
dollars of wealth was destroyed because
of him businesses were crushed children
had been set back for their lifetimes
and he we're on a financial trajectory
to a a horrible burden in the coming
decades that he'll never pay the price
and I guarantee he gets a job from some
left-wing hack you know what Greg and
what she didn't mention is the money
that he makes off of uh medical
Pharmaceuticals well you know let's talk
about Kareem Kareem Jean-Pierre okay did
she have a right to do what she did and
shut people down I mean we can't ask a
decent question the one question the
world wants an answer to without her uh
you know running defense for this guy
yeah I mean imagine if a republican uh
back in 2001 you know lashed out from
the podium if somebody asked about 9 11
like can we do what do we know about not
whoa not this is the most important
question in modern history people should
want to know how their relatives died uh
but then again she's not honest about
crime or inflation you can't expect
expect them to be honest about this I
love that when they referred to fauci as
a guest like he's Taylor Swift making a
cameo to impress The Starry eye members
of the press he is still an employee who
is required to ask questions he's not a
celebrity he's a civil servant who like
you said makes a lot of money he makes I
think 800 Grand from the government
alone this again is like love him or hey
to me you got to bring up Trump because
you always have to do this comparison
and that is He Still Remains the most
transparent politician I've ever seen
whether he was right or wrong he still
loved the asking questions even the
dumbest questions he would ask and
oftentimes the dumbest questions would
get the most interesting answer that's
the question that was asked by the
reporter is precisely the question Trump
was asking like where is this crap
coming from that's what makes him closer
to Americans than say these gain of
function deniers that are currently
trying to cover their ass and I
understand why because I think that
America
when we can't just blame China on this
if we're behind the if we're paying for
this exactly so what's going to happen
is that we may have a little bit of
blood on our hands because we're paying
for the gain of function which created
this thing and uh as for JP it's amazing
how she doesn't even pretend that she's
trying to do her job do you know what I
mean at least pretend you're doing it
but you know she's operating under lower
standards right you know I mean she took
the right boxes she doesn't have to do
her job yep and she's not great at it
and by the way I mean but it doesn't
matter she's a spin doctor she's not
someone who gives information to the
American people no she hasn't even gone
to medical school she's not a doctor
Jessica the question that I have of you
is it was fauci's Agency on the Nia age
that gave five million dollars uh in new
grants for the same Wuhan link group
Echo Health Alliance despite U.S
intelligence assessing a lab release was
there was one of only two explanations
you know and yet everybody on the left
is defending him well I think there's a
difference between defending Anthony
fauci and saying that we should
understand where a disease that killed
millions of people across the globe and
over a million Americans came from I've
been consistent on that I want to know
exactly what happened there were a
number of stories starting with a
Pangolin whatever that is in a wet
market and ending up now where most
people who I talk to and they're
generally of the liberal persuasion
thinks that it came from a lab and they
would like to know what happened there
so that feels like a real piece of
bipartisan agreement that we can go to
and there are other Western democracies
I believe majority of them that also
fund gain of function research we're not
going to be the only ones that were
linked with funneling money into this
lab why is the press secretary not
allowing the question to be asked of him
that is so far above my pay grade it
would not be how I comments all the time
what am I supposed to say I would answer
the question if I was the press
secretary I would answer the question or
I would say to my boss I have to answer
this question what about this advice
that I talked about about a line about
mask line about the vaccine yeah so I
think and those people you did you did
admit that it was other Trump other
officials of the administration Jerome
Adams who was the Surgeon General who
has since apologized for it I think that
they didn't know what to do when
resources were so scarce and obviously
doctors and nurses and the people who
were working in the hospitals First
Responders were the ones who needed
those masks more than those of us who
could stay at home America doesn't do
that we don't get to choose who the mass
everybody matters everybody life matters
everybody was still roam in the street
everyone deserves the mass doctors
working in the ER deserved masks more
than me period end of story can I just
comment on a couple things Dagen said
Anthony fauci is this blatant partisan
he has served in multiple Democratic and
Republican Administration he is not a
partisan stop
stop to the point about Trump being the
most transparent about this Carl
Bernstein has him on tape admitting that
he knew that the disease was Airborne
even though he came out and told
Americans that it wasn't
and I want to say something about
Tylenol and RSV because I went to my
pediatrician with my daughter who's
turning one and it was the only thing
that she talked to me about about
keeping kids out of they go to these
little baby classes you know they go to
a playground infect each other right and
I'm lucky I I had bought two bottles of
Tylenol that's a really serious crisis
if those shelves are empty of Children's
Tylenol going into the holidays and you
know what the shelves are empty they're
showing all kinds of you know in States
up the Eastern Seaboard shelves
I hope it doesn't turn into the new
formula crisis but that's something
there are no there are no options like
there weren't before you can't give them
a regular dose of any drugs so that has
to be dealt with right away well she
said AIDS was airborne and it wasn't
good times
when he focused on the vaccine